para algunos británicos este es un
regalo navideño
incluso si no votaron para dejar el
bloque ciertos londinenses dicen que
están aliviados con el acuerdo que
finalmente alcanzaron la unión europea y
reino unido- tras 10 meses de intensas
negociaciones
preferiría permanecer en el bloque pero
me tranquiliza que esto haya terminado y
ahora el debate se acabó necesitamos
continuar y bill clinton de cierto modo
plantear la pregunta sobre si el acuerdo
va a ser mejor que lo que teníamos antes
de que dejemos la unión europea y el
texto del acuerdo aún no ha sido
publicado pero el primer ministro boris
johnson dijo que era un buen trato para
toda europa
kings lo que significa que ambas partes
evitaron un final caótico el proceso del
éxito y los negocios no enfrentarán
aranceles a los bienes que atraviesen el
canal
en francia la sociedad está dividida
sobre este divorcio creo que está bien y
creo que francia debería hacerlo mis
padres
los británicos se darán cuenta que no es
una situación viable económicamente y
contrario a su pensamiento de querer
irse cambiarán de opinión
en escocia donde la mayoría votó para
quedarse en la unión europea el llamado
independentista persiste personalmente
preferiría que escocia sea parte de
europa así que esa es la forma en la que
votaré votaré por la independencia y
para que escocia vuelva a ser parte de
la unión europea tanto los parlamentos
europeos y británicos tienen que
ratificar el pacto antes de que reino
unido se divorció del bloque el primero
de mirón